hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday December 19th 2022.
uh almost the end of 2022 what's going
on how are you
um
oh my God
Jesus Christ uh where do I mean what do
I even talk is there anything else to
talk about
other than that game yesterday well bill
there's a lot of things to talk about
you could talk about the World Cup uh
evidently it was the greatest final of
all time
I uh
missed it missed most of it that I
watched the end of it
and even that part was exciting I
watched uh I don't know what part I
watched and then they I guess they do
the penalty kicks in the end because
everybody's tired they couldn't just
keep running around out there is that
what it is it did it was amazing there's
a lot of people to think I actually
don't like that sport or that I really
don't understand it or anything like
that and the reality is I just like
getting you guys going I keep telling
you this these [ __ ] idiots
I was sitting that tweet and going like
I mean you know at the end of the day I
could hit a penalty kick
you know he's [ __ ] people just look
you actually you couldn't
you could you think you could but you
could if your blood [ __ ] hurt it's
like dude I
I would be lucky if I if I hit the
[ __ ] ball and didn't follow my back
I'm just [ __ ] around so
congratulations to Argentina
you know
not only do they win their first one
since I want to say 86
is that what it was they wanted 78 and
86 that's right uh congratulations to
them and I always I love everybody in
South America because they like the same
bands I do
they [ __ ] they go nuts when they go
to the AC DC guns and roses and all
those bands I like Motley Crue when they
[ __ ] go bananas so uh good for them
you guys know I love France I was kind
of I didn't carry the way to be honest
with you France one it'd be great to see
first person to repeat
in a while
um
I will say that I am jealous
of soccer fans
I just have to pause this oh blimey mate
is [ __ ] football right yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] Rockstar Force I don't give a [ __ ]
it's called soccer over here because we
already have something called football
we already do but why do you call it
football I don't know
I don't know why over here if I say I'm
bummed out it means I had a bad day but
over in England it means I got [ __ ] in
the ass because things are different
you know
what are you English [ __ ] gonna get
over that and stop making the same point
every 5 000 [ __ ] times they [ __ ]
you know one of my favorite stories
about not knowing what was going on
in the world is some politician went to
some country and he showed up
as well as old school things that you
pull up in the plane you get off a
Tarmac and there's a bunch of people
behind a chain link fence like the
Beatles were doing their first tour
right and he gets off the [ __ ] plane
and everybody waves to him but he gives
him the thumbs up sign right
because that means like all right way to
go we're all together but in that
country it meant up yours
I sound like Keith Richards I know
oh
[ __ ]
um
ah Jesus Christ
uh
how funny is that that's just like
you know
it'd be like if somebody from another
country got off we all cheered hey
the leader of Bolivia is here and he
gets off the plane this gives us all the
finger and he goes from chair and for
like what the [ __ ] I remember like the
uh
I've talked about this before who is
that [ __ ] Russian Richard Nixon
looking guy
Boris Karloff what the [ __ ] was his name
he was before Gorbachev Gorbachev
uh you look like Droopy Dog as a
dictator
Brezhnev was that his name
Russians always had those names we just
like I wouldn't [ __ ] with that guy
Gorbachev
Brezhnev right
um
yeah when he came to some historic
agreement I guess I think there was
Nixon when he went to get when he came
out
to celebrate he made that clasp like
the champ used to well you you
you basically grab both your hands you
shake it to the right of the ear and to
the left of the ear and to him that
meant like togetherness
that we were all like does this [ __ ]
call me Pinko think he wants something
anyway
um
so this is where I'm at now I I caught a
cold it's just
but everything is done though
everything's done I am completely worn
out and run down and all of that [ __ ]
you know what's funny if somebody was
telling me like dude you got to get one
of those [ __ ] IV bags with the
[ __ ]
you know the vitamin solution in it and
all that [ __ ]
so I did it
and they say it's going to kick in today
so I am still waiting
still waiting for it to kick in I'm
waiting for that boost of energy I'm
hoping it's gonna work
uh
yeah look at me I'm a [ __ ] mess I got
goddamn IV tubes going in and out of me
but here's the thing
my tour is done the movie is done
and my Patriots are done Jesus [ __ ]
Christ
just when you thought the biggest Sports
story
was that Argentina won the World Cup ah
that's on the back pages here in America
they're putting that out there with the
[ __ ] women's volleyball
uh the [ __ ] New England Patriots I
was at the game man I was there man
and what I hate
is that whole game is gonna they're
gonna talk about the lateral play why
would you do it
the game was tied just step out of
bounds
what was
[ __ ] Myers thinking throwing it back
to
Mac Jones like what was Matt Jones gonna
[ __ ] do I mean you saw when he did
that naked bootleg
he knew he wasn't getting the first out
he was like Serpentine just trying to
run out run [ __ ] time off the clock
and all of that oh and they threw it
back and that's all they talk about
police stupid [ __ ] thing I'm telling
you dude it's a the [ __ ] defense that
we put in on that final drive
when they caught that touchdown that
looked like he was out of bounds but
we'll never know we'll never know
because the NFL despite the fact of
making billions and billions of [ __ ]
dollars a year just for some reason
cannot get a [ __ ] video camera on the
sidelines they just cannot [ __ ] do it
they can't get a camera lined up right
on the goal line it's always at a
[ __ ] angle you can't quite tell
why is that and why when they zoom in is
it all pixelated
like it's a YouTube video that was
uploaded in 2006 why is that
because it looked to me like that guy
was out of bounds but with the
pixelation it's like well is that the
out of bounds line or is that his cleats
his cleats are white the call on the
field was that it was a catch so they
made the right call in that
they had to go with that call but it
looked like it was [ __ ] wrong but
when they zoomed in there was no way to
tell why is that people
but that's not even what I'm mad about
what I'm mad about
is David Carr one of the few people in
the world that actually has a noticeably
bigger head than me was not able to move
the ball at all in the second half
at all and I was saying to my buddies
I was going the mpvp of this [ __ ]
guys she got a [ __ ] game ball for the
Raiders is their goddamn punter that guy
is a [ __ ] All-Pro
he was he put on a [ __ ] Clinic
a [ __ ] he kept pinning us down they
couldn't move the ball
he kept pinning us down on the other
side of the field and he would kick
these booming punts that hung up there
so long one of his own guys actually
caught one of the punts on the [ __ ]
one yard line
it was literally their strategy they
were just like well we can't score at
this point
but you know our offense is so [ __ ]
predictable and anemic for whatever
reason
that they're only going to maybe get one
first down 15 yards total and they're
gonna have to punt again and we'll just
keep keep eating up the clock that's
what the Raiders were doing
the Raiders like we can't move the ball
Patriots can't move the ball let's just
keep having are the second coming of Ray
guy just keep booting it down the other
side of the field I actually
really enjoyed whoever that puncher is
number six that [ __ ] guy is the [ __ ]
right so
the reality is is you can only do that
for so long
you let somebody in the game and
eventually
you let up a big play they go down and
they [ __ ] score so we've tied the
[ __ ] game or what I don't even know
what we did we went ahead
oh it was a whirlwind
it was a whirlwind of emotion
of emotion I am in a glass box
of sports Gambler emotion I had the
Patriots minus one by the way
yeah meanwhile I'm watching the game
Chandler Jones yet another great draft
pick for the Patriots that we didn't
want to play was just [ __ ] up our
[ __ ] all day I remember we had this
screen pass and people looking like in
the incredible with the kind of [ __ ]
passes after Matt Jones it's like you
didn't see Chandler Jones right in the
middle of it so he didn't throw the
[ __ ] Robert Parish foul shot over him
he [ __ ] that whole play up
the guy was an absolute Beast right it
was very apropos
if I could say that word with my pinky
out as I sip on a [ __ ] cup of tea
here that he intercepted the ball
and it just ran over Matt Jones
other people go why did they tackle him
um because [ __ ] Chandler Jones is an
X-Men
maybe that's why because he could
[ __ ] lower his shoulder
and Superman would get knocked back and
he they'd bring they at least bring out
the chains I'm not saying Superman
wouldn't stop him
uh
be funny watching Superman arguing the
spot
actually he wouldn't because he's a
superhero and he's just so [ __ ]
better than everybody so anyway my
problem with that [ __ ] game
is that David Carr look at the big brain
on Brad could not move the goddamn ball
down the field the whole [ __ ] time
and you know what when we went ahead and
we scored that touchdown [ __ ] Raiders
fan behind me was hilarious he was
called God damn it we do this every
[ __ ] week
he was spiraling down catastrophizing I
said buddy
I said buddy don't worry about it I go
don't worry about we're going to go into
a prevent defense and we're just going
to give up the field in four plays down
to the 20-yard line and you're going to
get four shots at the end zone I'm not
saying you're gonna win but you're gonna
get four shots at the end zone and then
he goes dude don't [ __ ] out negative
me about my you know I'm doing the
negative thing and I said dude I'm
showing solidarity so we both laughed
and what are the pages too they didn't
go into like a prevent they went into I
think you know like a soft Zone over the
middle and just sort of gave up the
middle of the field and all of a sudden
David Carr
God bless the big-headed fella who
couldn't move the [ __ ] ball goes
right down the [ __ ] field Bang
bang
this is him yeah Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
if they had played defense like they had
the rest of the game that wouldn't have
happened
very good
little Reservoir Dogs for you bad
version but whatever
he goes right down the [ __ ] field
like he's Joe Montana
all right and then they get that now
they have their four shots at the
[ __ ] End Zone and then they get one
great throw great catch what is this
oh these traveling salesmans just love
to set the alarm
who sets an alarm for 11 6 56.
A.M
cokehead
is that cheated on his wife
I'm in Vegas right now
you know what this is the thing when you
can't figure out how to there we go you
just [ __ ] I unplugged it and it's
still ringing
Jesus Christ I thought he had to go and
find the app
go into settings
and click on what the [ __ ] is wrong with
my alarm
um
anyway so like the second play I think I
don't know
on the second play they [ __ ] uh
it's a great pass great catch really
close
didn't look like it was in God knows I'm
biased but I I will say this there was
the right call that they didn't [ __ ]
um reverse that
then reverse the call because with that
[ __ ] picture you know those [ __ ]
douches on the internet who just
recycled jokes was was this film with
the potato right like how many times did
they use that joke
um
there was definitely there was when they
zoomed in on it I'm like it still looks
like he's out but there's no way that's
conclusive and the longer it was taken
you know my buddies are going like this
isn't good if they came right back it's
you know this is gonna be
this is not going to be good for us
innocent verdict comes back quick guilty
takes a little bit longer so uh that was
it
and then that other [ __ ] that just
happened uh I mean I mean I don't even
know what to say that was like [ __ ]
the Benny Hill show but my real thing is
I am thoroughly convinced
uh people have been saying it for years
I really believe
that the preventive events the soft Zone
whatever you want whatever you want to
call it
is a marketing plan by the NFL
to make games that are over not over
games where you could just [ __ ]
you know if they just play defense you
know they're going to go you mean you
got to get a four and out which is hard
but if you're fighting for every [ __ ]
yard
well what if he gets behind you hang up
behind you the whole half you think that
was a [ __ ] fluke
I am 100 convinced that they go into
that thing
so every game becomes three two one what
the [ __ ]
and that the I bet I'm I am I'm jaded
I'm not gonna lie to you I am jaded I'm
in this [ __ ] business and I know all
these this is entertainment like
anything else all they give a [ __ ] about
is the dollar
and I bet some [ __ ] nerds
some [ __ ] nerds went in there and
they said the problem is a lot of these
games are over with like seven minutes
left
you know so advertisers they don't want
to play top dollar for this point of the
game see our Peak advertising dollar is
between the the 10 minutes into the
first quarter in 7.3 minutes can we
somehow make the whole game like that
what could we do
all right and it was a I don't think
this literally fixed but I just really
believe that
this whole thing this this air quote we
need to protect quarterbacks they don't
give up they're only protecting
quarterbacks because they know if the
starting quarterback is out the average
football fan isn't interested
Kyler Murray goes down no one wants to
see that Colt McCoy is actually a
[ __ ] really good quarterback they
know because the star isn't in there so
they protect the quarterback they make
all of these [ __ ] rules to make it
easier to score so the passive fan
watches watches it and I think it's all
like the NBA everything is like finessed
to have it have the most dramatic ending
ever because in uh I'm sure I'm just
paranoid I'm sure this comes off the
sour grapes I'm not taking anything away
from the Raiders because 100 we deserve
to lose that game 100 that game was not
fixed but I just
somebody who who actually coaches
okay because I'll sit there and I'll
just throw out numbers be like 80 of the
time you go to the prevent defense they
go right down the field they get four
shots at the end zone
and they'll probably say well actually
it's more like 37 or 42 percent of the
time
it just feels like 80 of the time
because you're an emotional lunatic and
I'll go with that
all right but my thing is 37 is still
really high
like what what maybe one [ __ ] thing
that they do during the game that has a
37
failure rating
if a pass had a 37 chance of getting
picked off they wouldn't [ __ ] throw
it but at the end of so many of these
[ __ ] games
they just give it up
we're not going to play defense to you
down to like the 30 or the 25 yard line
then we're going to play the D that was
stopping you for the whole game that's
what we're gonna try until then we're
just gonna try to keep you you know
they'll even protect the sideline I
don't know
uh
I want to talk to somebody in the NFL
some point in this podcast and ask them
why they can't get
a camera right on the goal line cameras
right on the sidelines I mean you
literally have a camera going way down
the field on a [ __ ] wire
you got people on those other ones on
those forklift cameras running over
people at Sofi Stadium right
you got that [ __ ] going on
all right they make glasses now that
have cameras on them
they could be talking to somebody
they're literally filming you
um
I mean it's a pervert's world this
[ __ ] camera is everywhere this
cameras literally everywhere I saw a
[ __ ] thing with these this Father and
Son went to the [ __ ] wilderness
and they came upon these hibernating
bears
and it's illegal to shoot them and these
pieces of [ __ ] shot him
and shot the uh the cubs too the guy's
like that's how we roll middle of
nowhere this [ __ ] Forest Montana
Alaska I don't know where the [ __ ] it
was guess what it ended up being on film
because some ragers had put a [ __ ]
camera in the goddamn tree
to try to look at the [ __ ]
hibernation habits of a goddamn bear
they got caught and whatever the [ __ ]
happened happened to him
that was on film
however a touchdown
in an NFL game
that the footage of undeniably where his
foot was or where it was it just does
not exist
why is that
all right but then the rest of you can
[ __ ] play Benny Hill music under the
[ __ ] lateral and all of that [ __ ]
um
that's just the biggest bonehead play
maybe ever that's the biggest bonehead
play I've seen since that guy in the
Saints for some reason took his eyes
off that uh receiver and dove into his
own player
and lost the game that is arguably I
will say this about Chandler Jones
runs over a guy and at the 10-yard line
is holding the ball out before he even
crosses the goal like like how many
times does the Don baby have to come
down and slap it out of you
that would have been hilarious if he
actually spiked it before he got in
there uh
to me anyway so
all right here's the upside is a
Patriots fan I believe that eliminated
us from the playoffs which is fantastic
so maybe we can draft
get a better draft pick and this this
whole experiment where we couldn't call
Matt Patricia or hire a offensive
coordinator because if we did then the
Lions didn't have to pay for it like
whatever this this is like you know
our whole game plan this year was like
an old lady going to the supermarket
wait you know she's pulling out all the
coupons
we don't want to pay for an offensive
coordinator so we're going to call Matt
Patricia our maitre d real estate agent
in charge of
um feelings when we have the ball
whatever his [ __ ] title is
does not seem to be working so
I don't know what to tell you with that
with that that is the that is that is my
stand-up comedian has not played
organized football since the 70s take on
what the [ __ ] I saw there I I eventually
I want to get a coach on my podcast to
explain to me to talk me off the [ __ ]
cliff
that uh and I want to just I just need
to be talked off the ledge and convince
me that the prevent defense soft Zone
over the middle is the way to go at the
end of a [ __ ] game
that if you want to win the game the way
to win the game is to stop playing
[ __ ] defense
until you get to your own 20-yard line
I I you know whatever
um
okay upside I went to the Raiders
stadium uh again which is [ __ ]
amazing I was there with all my high
school buddies I used to hang out with
dude the [ __ ] Boston accents I was so
bummed my my wife wasn't there bobbed so
many things right now he got [ __ ] in
the ass in Vegas what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas mate was it a penalty
kick
did you dive the right way
um
um
we were driving over to the stadium and
I never noticed how many casinos had an
R for the last name
always going to do it you have a minute
the Excalibur
nah dude isn't that owned by C
I think they're the [ __ ] luxa
I think it's the [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] phone man I swear to
[ __ ] Christ
get up I don't want to [ __ ] answer
the phone call
Jesus Christ remind me but remind me in
an hour I have to [ __ ] get back to
you
Jesus [ __ ] Christ do you know I'm
staying in this [ __ ] goddamn casino
right I [ __ ] go to call room service
they don't even answer the phone
they tell me I have to go to a website
and leave my phone number to get a
goddamn BLT
it's like how is that easier why can't I
just have a menu where is the menu is it
on the TV do I have to point my phone at
something
I know I sound like a [ __ ] old guy
right now but I'm telling you like this
whole thing like now you have my phone
number
you know and then what are you gonna use
that as a revenue stream to sell it to
somebody else I was trying to have a fun
time here
after the goddamn um
taking this [ __ ] loss here um yeah my
friends are going over there going like
yeah I think it's all by season I
thought it was all by luxa
they pulled up to the state
was that amazing yeah shop
and I also
yeah Regis fans dress up as characters
the best one ever uh we ran into the guy
that uh
that dresses up like Al Davis I mean his
the shape of his head the way he Combs
his hair he dresses all in white with
the black sneakers and then he's got the
granny chains with the glasses in it
we yeah me and my buddies all got a
picture with the guy he's got like the
Super Bowl ring he has like his energy
and it was awesome because we were we're
like the Raiders facility was playing
that old school NFL films
you know that remember that trumpet song
[Music]
show the highlights see we're playing
that and this [ __ ] guy comes walking
out dead ringer
for Al Davis
and we all went nuts like cheering for
him and he at first he went like yeah
then he saw your Patriots fans that he
gave us the finger we all laughed you're
like buddy can we get a picture with you
he goes that'd be great
uh
so shout out to whoever that guy is that
guy to me wins the title
um
he should just walk around like that
with NFL films music playing it's just
fun it's just [ __ ] amazing
uh so
anyway
I guess I gotta do some reads now
sorry guys I'm really not this upset
about a stupid ass football game it's
just I am so [ __ ] sick of being sick
and I I I'm finally getting off the
goddamn Road
um all right let me just do some some of
the reads here
uh right here we click on this
ah oh the live reads oh look who it is
everybody it's butcher box
uh butcher box takes the guesswork out
of finding high quality Meat and seafood
you can trust 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken that doesn't
[ __ ] lateral on the last play of the
game of a tie game pork raised crate
free wild caught Alaskan salmon
you don't know what it's going to do is
it gonna throw it back to [ __ ] Mac
Jones humanely raised no antibiotics or
added hormones get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep free
show free ship like the free Victory we
gave the Raiders for the continental U.S
and no surprise feast
no surprises I would like that after yes
they enjoy a range of high quality cuts
that are hard to come by at the grocery
store
at an amazing value exclusive member
deals so you can save big on your
favorite Cuts recipes inspiration guides
tips and hacks some are even
personalized so you can cook up
mouthwatering Meals
uh I love knowing my freezer is full of
quality food for my family this holiday
season is made better and tastier with
butcher Buffs for a limited time they're
offering our listeners ground beef for
life and 20 off your first order
uh sign up today at butcherbox.com and
use code bird to get 20 off your first
box and ground beef for life of your
membership that's butcherbox.com and use
the code Burr b-u-r-r
all right look who it is everybody so
indochino find the perfect suit fighting
the perfect suit is impossible but
finding a suit that's perfect for you is
simple thanks to indochino
I don't even know what that means
finding the perfect suit
is impossible but finding a suit that's
perfect for you is simple
that's what he's saying I'm not perfect
like a perfect suit is impossible but
you know we can get a suit for you
um choose your favorite Fabric and
customize every detail to find the look
that's perfect for you submit your
measurements online or get measured in
store for a custom made for you fit at
an incredible price and their with their
fall collection featuring new colors in
premium Fabrics you'll be in style all
season long every indochino suit is made
for just you it is Taylor it's a
tailored experience at a great price
designed to look design a look that
suits you perfectly for the fabric to
the cut shop they are made for you suits
starting at just 449
and premium fitted shirts starting at
just 89 you can fine tune every detail
lapels lightings Monograms and more get
a premium personalized wardrobe without
spending a fortune shop customized
fitted suits casual wear outerwear and
more
outerwear what is what the [ __ ] is out
they're always adding I know what
underwear is outerwear I mean pants
they're always adding new designs and
fabrics up
it's still coffee on my [ __ ]
outerwear there's always they're always
adding new designs and fabric options
like their latest fall collection can
you get canceled for that they're called
Pants anymore they're called outerwear
CIS [ __ ] slack wearing douche uh
ready to elevate your look even further
indochino lets you make any suited tucks
design your perfect suit with indochino
get 10 off any purchases of 3.99 or more
use the promo code Burr at indochino.com
that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code burn
all right oh Simply Safe
did you know that property crimes like
burglaries and package thefts Spike over
the winter
oh my God you haven't seen those videos
for those pieces of [ __ ]
just come walking up I mean I swear to
God
I mean that's when you just wish you
could see a Pit Bull with a bad odor
and the results of that uh that's why
now is the time to secure your home with
award-winning Home Security
simply you know what they should start
doing is they should just they put the
fake passages packages out there they
should just start tasing people
that they just find like it just have
like Cuban cigars
the fact that I know most 99.9 of them
are fake I don't even try to get one
anymore
if they would just tased 99.9 of the
people trying to steal a package that
would be over uh simply say if it's the
home security system I recommended
all right I recommend it
um make it your resolution to start the
new year with great greater peace of
mind and safety for you and your family
Simply Safe With staying the best home
security system of 2022. this happens
almost every year by U.S news and World
Report a third year and a third year in
a row it's a dynasty in an emergency 24
7 Professional monitoring agents use
fast protect TM technology exclusively
from Simply Safe to capture a fish uh
capture critical evidence and verify the
threat is real so you can get priority
police response Simply Safe is the whole
home security with Advanced senses for
every room window and door HD security
cameras for inside and out smarter ways
to detect motion that alert you only
when a threat is real and even Hazard
sensors that detect fires floods and
other threats to your home 24 7
Professional monitoring Services cost
hundred dollar a day less than half the
price of atd's traditional
professionally installed system with
top-rated SimpliSafe app with each
operated Simply Save app stay in control
uh complete control of your system
anytime anywhere armor disarm unlock for
a guest access your camera or adjust
system settings customize the perfect
system for your home in just a few
minutes at simplysafe.com go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
20 off your order with interactive
monitoring that's
s-m-i-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com
simplisafe.com there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
um all right well with that let's let's
do the reads here
I apologize I feel like I was extra
grumpy but sometimes I know a lot of you
guys enjoy listen to me completely lose
my [ __ ] over [ __ ] alarms
whatever I just I've been on the road to
love that's all uh all right bottled it
origin oh here
even one of these [ __ ] English [ __ ]
over there I was just assuming it's from
England
you know because they always write in
because for some reason they they just
want to still feel relevant
even at like the podcasting level
I'm just [ __ ] with you hey Billy
baked bean Bunce I hope you you're
you're well and set up for Christmas
with the family I was listening to your
podcast on my drive to work on Tuesday
and you mentioned the origin of the term
bottled it
yeah
it's one of these poor bastards
you know just missed the net
on a penalty kick I guess this is based
on something called Cockney rhyming
slang
which is was a way of speaking and code
that I believe came from the Dock
Workers in the east side of London back
in the day
the term I use when I don't actually
know
when it was
um
anyone from East London is referred to
as a cockney the way it works is that
instead of saying the word you want to
say you have two words that are
associated with one another
and the two words rhyme with the actual
word you wanted to say
it sounds like a pig latin thing you
then only say the first word of the two
when
you're using it to disguise what you're
saying lost yet
um all right
this is this is not [ __ ] calculus I'm
a for example lost his bottle actually
means lost his ass
yeah so what I was saying last week I
read this because the coffee rhyming
slang for the ass is bottle and glass
okay
uh certainly in England a lot of people
use Cockney rhyming slang without
realizing if you want to draw someone's
attention to something you will often
hear
have a butcher at this
and that comes from butcher's hook
equaling look
seems like a long way to go to say look
um
is this like East London's Yiddish
because I never realized how much
Yiddish I use
um although we don't use a lot of coffee
[ __ ] uh you can have multiple coffee
rhyming slang words in one sentence
which makes things even more confusing
okay so in other words these guys were
doing some illegal [ __ ]
foreign
Jesus Christ
um
all right I know what you guys are
thinking why don't you go see a doctor
because I'm German Irish all right we
just [ __ ] ride [ __ ] out
that's how it works I got a [ __ ] IV
yesterday right
I feel better except for my [ __ ] nose
this Miner's cough that I have
um
like I got that RSVP respiratory virus
maybe I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
um
I don't know what it is but I blame the
Liberals
that's actually not true it's because
you guys out in your red star
um have a butcher at her okay I got uh
okay I got a pop-up
the apples to grab my dog
all right let me guess what that means I
gotta pop up to my apples to grab my dog
that means I gotta get the balls to beat
the [ __ ] out of this country
uh this means I gotta pop upstairs to
grab my phone
why would you need to disguise that
apples and pears stairs dog and bone
phone
Roy I gotta pop up the apples to grab me
my dog
okay it's quite an interesting style of
speech it really is and it's involved
over the years with some rhyming slang
being modernized in the 90s boat race
evolved to Chevy Chase leading face
so you would say I got Harry all over
her Chevy Chevy
if you look up the coffee rhyming slang
for Harry
um all right all I know is I hope I
never do a show in East London because
I'm not going to understand the heckles
all right
definitely something looking into
worth looking into as it's quite
interesting it is but maybe not as
beneficial as learning French unless you
plan on doing a set and coffee rhyming
slang in the near future no I don't I
would never attempt to do that love the
podcast to stand up and all your work
have a great festive period thanks for
all the bubbles and go [ __ ] yourself
bubbles
rugs with troubles
um
thanks for all the troubles are you
[ __ ] on bubbles troubles
Barney Rubble your Flintstone fan I
can't figure it out all right F is for
family graffiti
oh this was the coolest thing ever hey
Billy snare tits looks like Frank Murphy
and Smokey
uh it's actually Rosie have made it big
time I think it was Rosie I thought it
was Rosie
um
somebody sent these pictures
that they took on a freight train and
believe it or not it's actually of two
of the characters
from
um
[ __ ] are they
I was clicking on this and now it's all
gone
where is it yeah that's Rosy not Smoky
Rosie and Frank Murphy on the side of a
freight train in Vancouver
how about that for street cred
we got the street kids from Canada
putting graffiti on a train that was
actually really cool uh whoever did that
I want to give a shout out you did a
great job I'm gonna post the pictures
when I figure out how to do that and
um I sent them to Mike Price the captain
of the efficient family ship and he was
absolutely over the moon that somebody
cared enough to um
paint those it was really really cool
um so
so there's that all right noise induced
hearing loss hi Mr Burr
um I recently stumbled across a few of
your rants regarding noise exposure and
how the world is too noisy I am
currently in graduate school to earn my
doctorate in Audiology oh here we go
you're absolutely right about the noise
levels in today's world music TV levels
at bars and restaurant can cause
permanent hearing damage in as little as
five minutes if it reaches a certain
decibel level sporting events subway
stations vacuums and even some air
dryers you can have serious consequences
as well I have a decibel app and daily I
find myself in environments and daily I
find myself in environments that are
above safe noise levels you know one of
the the only popular public figures
talking about this very serious issue
yeah um
the only upside of this is that so many
people are going to end up with tinnitus
which I don't wish on anybody
that maybe they'll actually work on it
more and try to come up with a cure for
it but I can tell you like uh I saw a
little kid at the Raiders game yesterday
and he literally had on like he looked
like he had the leaf blower headphones
on which I was really happy for the dad
that he was doing that but I was looking
at the dad and he didn't have any I had
earplugs in the whole [ __ ] game
you know
[Music]
um
that was another funny thing about the
Raiders fans is the arrogance
of these you would think that they just
won a Super Bowl they won a [ __ ]
Super Bowl in 40 years
and they're like
Raiders like
anybody is like oh no
not the Raiders
the last time they won a Super Bowl
Ronald Reagan was in his first term
I mean I just like
what are they doing and then they also I
guess I mean I love that they play all
those NFL films and all of that [ __ ] but
they kind of got to let go of that
like the how the flyers I remember they
still always show all that Broad Street
Bully [ __ ] and everything it's like guys
you gotta [ __ ] move on you ever want
a [ __ ] Cup in 50 years let's try to
you know win a different way or
something I don't know what strange
um so anyway this guy says uh
it's a very taboo topic people wear
sunglasses to protect their eyes and
wear sunscreen to protect their skin but
very few people are focused on
protecting their hearing excessive loud
noise exposure has been correlated to uh
tinnitus perceived ringing in the ears
uh but what it actually is is now the
discovery it's like in the brain
and so there's over in Europe they had I
saw this thing I can't find it somebody
could find it they have this stuff where
you put on like headphones
and you work with the doctor or
something and you he tries to
figure out what pitch you're hearing in
your ear and then he plays whatever like
that Bose [ __ ] where you pay the play
the opposite note to cancel it out and
it allegedly resets your brain or at
least makes it not as loud
course it's not approved over here yet I
don't know if it works
who knows
anyway here we go work hey Bill huge fan
can't wait for old dads I've been
telling everyone about it when the topic
of new movies come up oh yeah I think
it's good I'm really really proud of it
I own a restaurant that my grandparents
started in the early 70s we have always
staffed with you we're always staffed
with younger kids looking for jobs or
adults looking for part-time work we've
been understaffed due to the last few
years events and are struggling to stay
operational uh we'll survive because
it's all we have and we'll make it in
the long run but finding people to work
in our area has been very difficult we
pay almost double the server base in our
kitchen positions have had two times
minimum wage since the 90s
I agree corporations are slimy and are
probably feeling the backlash to their
inhumanity but aside from that it's been
clear that younger people are not eager
to work
um
I just think that waiting tables
to them is like churning butter
when you can uh
I mean like it used to be if you're a
good looking chick you become a waitress
you make money making tips it's like why
do I want to do that when I can just go
on like Instagram and be like oh my God
you're like that's your ass and you know
kind of stick your finger in your mouth
a little bit
um
whatever the [ __ ] it is hot chicks do on
the internet
um
I think that that's what it is they have
that's not that they're not working I
mean they obviously are working how are
they paying their rent so I think that's
they're working I just think old people
like us don't really know what the new
jobs are
um
they can't all be in entertainment I
feel like they're
like everybody else they're always on
their phone and they're always consuming
content so I imagine they're trying to
get into that world
because that's the world they enjoy if I
was a younger person I would probably
want to get involved in creating video
games make an app
uh
um get in shape and I'll just be your
[ __ ] personal trainer through the
internet and then I can be at home
um
I think maybe like the combination of
that maybe and like also they just sort
of post-made foods
and no one goes to like malls anymore
I don't know I I'm too [ __ ] old to
figure it out but uh that is fascinating
I I don't think that they don't want to
work
I just think that they want a different
job than the jobs that we had which is
normal
anyway ten years ago we had teens and
college kids always coming back to work
for us I speak with many of the other
local businesses and they all have the
same problem part-time work is not
sought after I've heard from frustrated
parents who are customers that their
kids and their friends have sworn off
part-time work
when we do hire
they usually rep they they are usually
reprimanded for being on their phone
instead of working and quit soon after
I think there are two worlds of people
uh there's two worlds of people that
don't want to work there's always been
lazy people
but young people used to care about
making money I've had applicants scoff
at the pay Which is higher than anything
else
that they could get anywhere else for
part-time and no skills required well
obviously I would think it wouldn't be
if they're laughing at it
I would be fascinated to hear from
somebody young to say what jobs do
appeal to you anyways I'm sure the tide
will turn someday but it's unfortunate
that younger people
don't have the same culture of work
ethic
one new hire
quit because he said we don't give them
enough positive reinforcement after only
one week
please tell me that's a joke I told this
to my grandfather whose brain seemed
unable to compute thanks for the laugh
happy holidays to you and your family
all right look I tried to stick up for
young people in that one but Jesus
Christ
you don't give me enough I you know
I really think that
a lot of people can't handle being on
the internet
and having their face out there and I
think of a lot they're all like acting
like celebrities who used you know back
in the day you get your own TV show and
then act like a [ __ ] [ __ ] not
everybody but some people
um
I think it's kind of uh
maybe it's a uh
a symptom of of social media or
something like that I do know like uh
like you know I I tweeted out I've seen
it all after the Raiders thing
and then some kid wrote this joke said
me when I've seen it all talking about
you know what I've said so and I was
sitting there trying to figure out the
joke I was like I don't really get this
joke I know he's making fun of me
does he does he saying that like what I
said was stupid but the thing that I
couldn't get past was the me
um because I was just like what is what
I said have to do with you and I kind of
feel like
that's the disease that I see that I've
seen in my business where you watch
people get [ __ ] and then all of a sudden
this thing happens
with this you know not everybody but you
know that's you know some people I call
it taking the ride and then after a
while you just really can't hear or
compute things
unless it's about you
um
so uh
I I don't know I I I I don't think
everybody is like that I think there are
a lot of young people working out there
but um
I know it hasn't been healthy for me to
be on the phone as much as I'm on the
phone and then also parents are
definitely guilty of using the the
tablets and [ __ ]
reward and Punishment like I'll tell you
my daughter doesn't give a [ __ ] about
Santa Claus but if you go to take that
tablet away like it is
a Meryl Streep performance
and I've had to talk to her about it
going like look how upset you're getting
and what's amazing is the second if I go
to give it back to her all the tears
immediately stop so it's just a
performance so I just have to remind
myself of that it's like no you're gonna
hang out with me we're going to talk
we're going to connect you're going to
color you're going to draw you're gonna
do stuff that stimulates your brain
instead of staring at this thing I don't
have a problem
with
um with her looking at it because she's
going to go into a world of all
computers and she needs to be familiar
with how to interact with them but
definitely too much of it
is uh
not a good thing and then I also
feel like it's a very uh
everybody's just up their own ass
about like themselves like um
like my thing that's socially most
fascinated with right now is the word
woke
and how that word literally means
something different to every single
person that uses it because everybody
just you internalized it for themselves
you know
like I find it fascinating that white
liberals took the word from black people
and then put it on themselves and made
it like a compliment of what a great
white person they were and then they
started talking down to white people in
red States
so now to them like woke culture is some
annoying Hollywood white douche telling
them that they're not living their life
correctly
and
all of the stuff that it was supposed to
be about
basically not white people
is all out the window
and it's just white people yelling at
each other
when somebody says that to me
like I'm just like all right nah man I
had to get out of there because all that
woke [ __ ]
I'm like
I mean I live in L.A
if you didn't know that right
it sounds like you walk down the street
and people just yelling that [ __ ] when
you I mean it's a [ __ ] great place to
live I will tell you it is a [ __ ]
great place to live the weather is
amazing and all of that type of stuff
um I find more you run into that woke
[ __ ] when you're like pitching shows and
stuff like that but I feel like he
walked down the street
and somebody's yelling you hey you
walking down the street have you thought
about a transgendered person today let's
let's not like it's just
I don't know what it is
it's [ __ ] weird though
um
I don't know I'm probably guilty of a
two at some point at some level or
whatever you know what it is what I
realized I [ __ ] hate everybody
all right I hate both sides
I just I just don't [ __ ] like it as
far as like uh liberals and
conservatives I [ __ ] can't stand them
I [ __ ] I just I I don't know like
this can you believe we're gonna have to
sit through another [ __ ] presidential
election
you know can they just [ __ ]
you know stupid Joe Biden's gonna get
the nomination and then Republicans just
pick your [ __ ] guy and then that's it
then everybody shut the [ __ ] up and
we'll all vote nine months later
stop with the stupid we already know who
we're voting for
why are they dragging it out for money
right for money the election goes into
the [ __ ] prevent defense
the second of the presidential debates
like everybody already doesn't have
their [ __ ] minds made up I don't know
you know I'm on the fence here
it's like
think of that guy in the red tie makes
more points than the guy in the blue I
don't know you know
uh single pilot commercial flights all
right dear Billy expert brains
as a helicopter pilot you probably know
everything there is to know about flying
winged machines
insert you saying no I don't that's
exactly what I was going to say I don't
regardless I'd like you to weigh in on
this commercial airlines are lobbying
Congress to allow single pilot flights
oh they don't have a co-pilot I'm aware
that it's mostly computers handle yeah
but not the takeoff and Landing
if the flights
handle if like I'm aware that it's
mostly computers handle
if the flights
I don't know what you're trying to say
there and that remote operated planes
have been around as early as the 50s see
operation Northwoods
so say the One Pilot passes out or dies
of a heart attack
dude if you haven't been in an airport
and you see a guy with [ __ ] iFly
planes shirt on
dressed like Gavin McLeod on The Love
Boat rest his soul and you see him like
eating like a burger and fries I start
going please don't be flying my plane
anyway so say the One Pilot passes out
or dies of a heart attack would you
really trust a computer
land or make the adjustment call a human
would in an extra
pacifist situation
um
no I I obviously would because I don't
think a computer cares if it dies or not
yeah I think a computer's just like yeah
we can make it
we make it if we don't uh what do I give
a [ __ ]
I don't have a dog in this fight you
know
I wouldn't mind just [ __ ] going back
into the Earth and becoming something
they dig up again to turn into a [ __ ]
Nintendo switch
uh no I'm not into that
I've been to human beings flying planes
um
having said that I'm also in all that
computer technology if they can make it
safe enough that they don't need another
guy
I would think that would be awesome
while they still had two guys that's
what I would vote for
the thing is
is both you and I know why they're doing
this they're not doing this because it's
safer
they're doing it because they'd rather
pay for the system once than the pilot
for 20 25 years
so that's their deal
that's like the self-checkout which I've
just given into
because everybody else is doing it so I
just said [ __ ] it you know I just got
tired I'm not fighting anymore right
they don't have self-checkout to make it
more convenient for you they have it so
they don't have to pay for somebody
that's also one less person that could
be like hey somebody said nice tits to
me at work and I'm [ __ ] offended I'm
gonna Sue this play right computers
don't Sue they don't complain
they don't care
they don't give a [ __ ] they'll work 24
[ __ ] seven so I think that that's why
you
know
that's the direction that they're moving
in It's Gonna freak us out
because we grew up in a time when there
was people in the front of the plane and
eventually there will be no people in
the front of the plane they'll just be
computers and people will grow up with
that
the same way young people have grown up
with the government listening to all
their phone calls if they want to and
they don't question that because there
was never a time when they didn't the
same way my generation never questioned
uh paying you know federal and state
income tax
uh because it was always that way and uh
that's just kind of how it works that is
that is frightening though I would say
um
I mean Tesla already did those
self-driving cars and a couple people
got killed because it wasn't able to
read something
I mean dude how much I love you
what a [ __ ] way to go
2018 2019 2020 uh how did he die well he
was in a self-driving car
what a self-driving car they make them
things
um why has he got to be Southern bill
because I like doing the accent
I'm working on my Macho Man Randy Savage
though I am the Intercontinental
heavyweight champion yeah
um
anyway I just think it's uh
yeah it just it is what the [ __ ] out of
ways I have to die
I believe that my car
would drive itself to the point the guy
was taking a nap they went to sleep
that is the biggest selling point I
think of this of these self-driving car
wait a minute
that means I can go out and party till
four in the [ __ ] morning
I can sleep
a couple of hours wake up take a shower
and then sleep on the way to work you're
going to be hoping this traffic
um
I think self-driving cars 100 are going
to happen I don't know that they're safe
or whatever but I think uh people are
just gonna be like oh I love driving you
know
I just shut my phone off I go to sleep
I'm in Rhode Island I wake up you know
it's like I'm in [ __ ] Buffalo New
York
it's great I feel refreshed it's good
for your brain you know sleep is saying
with these studies helps to save up
Dimension all the same [ __ ]
um
yeah I don't know I will tell you this
on my on this this break that I'm taking
here
a couple of months here from working I
am definitely going to be flying a lot
and uh
not even a lot I'm not gonna do anything
a lot except trying to get over this
[ __ ]
Avalanche of [ __ ]
coughing and sneezing um all right that
is the podcast everybody thank you for
listening thank you to everybody who
came out to the uh Slight Return tour
thank you to the legendary club soda
Kenny
um the greatest tour manager security
guy in the history of the business I put
him right up there with [ __ ] Peter
Grant of Led Zeppelin
he is just the [ __ ] man
that's it obviously thank you to
everybody who came out to the shows
um it was an insane insane run and this
last weekend
to get to perform in New Orleans Austin
Texas
and San Antonio Texas and seeing that
amount of people showing up is never not
going to be crazy to me so I really
appreciate it I'm going to keep writing
jokes and uh hopefully next year I'll
have another new hour or some [ __ ]
um
or whatever all right that is the
podcast go Patriots
I feel better congratulations to the
Raiders
uh
uh and I would say quite possibly
in a lot of ways I actually think that
the Raiders have the best stadium in the
league I actually like it better than
Sofi Sofi is a little too la
like it looks green screened
it is amazing
but
um
I think I like the Raiders better I do
think it's funny that Jerry Glanville
had to [ __ ] uh fix that TV
that he put the top of their Stadium
you know maybe not a big deal like how
big the [ __ ] TV was I remember
working the Dallas improv joking about
like that [ __ ] thing in three years
is gonna be the oldest biggest oldest
[ __ ] TV
like you can buy flat screen TV within
three years it can't it's not compatible
with [ __ ] and this guy has a [ __ ]
there's an 80 yard [ __ ] TV
I just thought that that was just so
perfect not only for Texas but for
Dallas I just loved it it's bigger it
means it's better
I mean that's some Ric Flair [ __ ]
uh I'll speak at a Ric Flair
James Khan is in a movie called uh
Thief
a Michael Mann movie and he's got this
scene I swear to God
or Tuesday Weld he's in a car and he
sounds like Ric Flair
he's yelling at her going you know he's
starting to date her and she doesn't get
him he goes
he goes what do you think I do huh
what do you think I do she's like you're
so so stupid [ __ ] cars that you're
you know used car deal thing he's like I
got a hundred and fifty dollar slaps I
got silk shirts I got a [ __ ] diamond
ring I was and I was watching go like
whoa
foreign
all right the car dealership is just how
I wash my money
and uh
that's the way it was done back in the
day
if you were dishonest man
and your girlfriend couldn't figure out
what you did for a living you yelled at
them
for not being observant enough to
realize
that you were in fact a criminal
um I highly recommend that and I also
watched Paul Newman the verdict
which was shot in Boston
uh amazing amazing amazing movie
absolutely loved it and you know what
was funny is like some of the bad Boston
accents
like I'll see you tomorrow in cot
instead of Court I'll see in [ __ ]
Court they always think pop the cardio
so it's cat no court I see in court dude
by an Alexa the Excalibur in its owned
by Caesars all right uh go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great couple of days
and I'll check in on you on Thursday